want to get to our other big story today
hundreds of Americans evacuated from the
epicentre of China's coronavirus
outbreak are coming home to the u.s.
this morning
one plant landed just north of San
Francisco only minutes ago a second
plane is expected soon and another
American is one of 10 passengers on a
cruise ship in Japan who tested positive
for the virus the overall death toll is
approaching 500 with more than 24,000
people infected overall ramie
innocencio is in beijing for us ramie
good morning what about those Americans
in China
good morning yeah we now know more than
500 Americans have been evacuated out of
Wuhan but time is running out for any US
citizens still there that's because the
State Department has confirmed that they
are now planning no more flights after
tomorrow desperate to get home around
350 US citizens border two planes last
night to escape Wuhan the center of the
corona virus epidemic priscilla Dickey
and her daughter Hermione were among all
those evacuated so excited they were
screened for symptoms before boarding
but will still be kept in quarantine for
up to 14 days in California what they're
leaving behind is a life on lockdown
where social media posts show the tough
measures some Chinese authorities are
taking this woman is said to have been
arrested in a grocery store for refusing
to wear a mask in another case a woman
gets into a fight after purportedly
refusing to have her temperature taken
other videos claimed to show authorities
dragging people away after they've shown
symptoms of the corona virus Beijing has
mobilized more than 7,000 tons of
supplies for people in Wuhan with the
army laying out thousands of empty beds
for more patients but infections in the
epicenter are spreading rapidly experts
have said that this epidemic could turn
into a pandemic how close are we to that
we're very close
dr. Ian Lipkin is advising Chinese
officials he did similar for the SARS
crisis here and says Beijing approach
has changed there is a
very different sort of sense here than
there was in 2003 everyone realizes that
the world was interconnected we all have
to do the best that we can and in Hong
Kong the city has now confirmed its
first death from the coroner virus that
is just the second outside of mainland
China after the Philippines and take a
look at this really compelling drone
video out of Hong Kong you can see so
many people standing in line by the
thousands just to buy a mass to protect
themselves we've just got a few here in
Beijing but I can tell you across China
across Asia and across America it's
really difficult to find these a very
hot commodity Anthony all right Remy
innocencio in Beijing thanks Randy